hey what's up my name's samuel leeds in
this video i'm going to be reacting
to the new budget yesterday there was a
new budget of 2021
massive tax implications for business
owners and property investors
also there's a lot of talk about
regeneration exactly what they're
planning on doing in the uk
tourism and support for businesses and
individuals so uh furlough and things
like that i've got it right here
it's only a few pages long you can read
this if you just type in new budget look
on the government website and read it i
would personally avoid
just listening to people's opinions on
it although that's what this is
but you know what people's opinions
often i'm gonna try and keep this super
super factual
and i'm just gonna read it okay i'm
gonna read it i'm gonna go through the
budget
not going to read every single point but
i'm going to read all the points that
could be relevant to you
me and my brother are going to react to
it russell russell leeds
multi-millionaire
so firstly i'm feeling overall i'm
feeling quite good i think quite good
about the budget i don't know how you're
feeling
yeah i'd agree with that i'd agree with
that i think the overall feeling of it
is yeah it's pretty good there's lots of
good things in there yeah i mean it's a
difficult time to do a budget isn't it
because obviously
the country is kind of on its knees
really with all the
the debt and everything from uh the
coronavirus but yeah
overall i agree i think it's pretty good
so listen this budget i don't want to
talk about coronavirus or covet at all
um uh it starts off talking about the
vaccinations
basically just to summarize they're
gonna they're gonna pump a load of money
into vaccinations so we can just skip
that
i want to move straight on to tax tax um
so okay firstly an extension to the
temporary cut and stamp duty land tax in
england and northern ireland
until september will will support the
housing market and protect and create
jobs what do you think about that
um i think it's good news well we
thought it was going to be till the end
of june until september
the um stamp duty yeah yeah we did think
it's gonna be until june
may so september's really really good so
what that means is basically then that
you're not going to have to pay any
stamp duty when you buy a house if
you're a first time buyer up to i think
it's 500 000 pounds
if you're not a first time buyer would
be capped at three percent up to i think
it's 250 grand
um so we're gonna save on stamp duty
yeah because
that was due to end in march a lot of
people were and
solicitors because we've just been
buying a lot of stuff at the moment the
solicitors have been so busy
like a bottleneck because everyone's
trying to complete before um before
march
to september i think the ramifications
of that
is going to be that it just keeps the
housing market going
that's going to be the ramification next
extension to the vat cut to the five
percent for hospitality accommodation
and attractions across the uk
until the end of september followed by
12.5 rate for a further six months until
the 31st of march 2022.
that's great news it is great news if
you're a hotel owner
or if you've got an accommodation
business if you've got a serviced
accommodation business that's
your v8 registered it's not going to
save you loads of money it's just going
to mean that your customers
what that's going to do is it's just
going to help you but what a lot of them
did like starbucks for example
because they didn't that they're sharing
that they're sharing it so
like they they didn't keep their prices
they actually put their prices up
but they also reduced it a bit so it was
like that they i think they're not like
50p off all their drinks
but they really should have knocked off
like one pound 50 or so i can't remember
the figures so
this is gonna do if you're in the
service accommodation business
okay or the hotel business um what's
going to happen is it's just going to
mean that
it's been hit really bad this is almost
i see because when i first saw that i
thought why are they actually saving tax
why are they shrinking tax for certain
types of businesses when they
need to recoup money because of the
furlough scheme and everything and then
i thought well actually it's because
they're trying to be fair to the hotel
business because the hotel business has
been hit so bad
and now they're saying look as a way of
supporting you as we come out of
lockdown
we're just going to reduce your vat from
what was it was it 20
20 right to 5 which is incredible and
then just 12 12.5
until the end of march 2022 so that's
great
next maintaining the income tax personal
allowance and higher rate threshold
from april 2022 until april 2026.
so what does that mean bro so that means
that you know obviously the moment you
can earn
for your personal tax it's what 12 and a
half 11 is it that's 12 and a half
right so basically you don't pay any tax
up to the first 12 and a half thousand
pounds yeah
and and and they're saying that that's
just going to stay okay like it is and
then your higher rate threshold which is
like
50 grand also i can't remember the exact
figures but somewhere around that yeah
it's gonna stay as it is as well so yeah
that's all
and can you still you know how the
moment when you set up a company
you're gonna pay yourself um 11 000
pounds
right or 12 and a half whatever it is
and you don't pay any tax on that and
then you can take a dividend
up to about 45 grand and pay just seven
and a half percent is that all
the same they're leaving it look
maintaining it's
yeah it's all staying the same that's
great that's really good news
next to balance the need to raise
revenue with the objective of having an
internationally competitive tax system
the rate of corporation tax will
increase to 25 percent
oh that's not great no for me it's not
which will remain the lowest rate in the
g7
okay in order to support the recovery
the increase will not take effect until
2023. that's good
really good businesses with profits of
50 000 pounds or less
around 70 of actively trading companies
will continue to be taxed at 19
okay and a taper of above 50 000 pounds
will be introduced
so that only businesses with profits
greater than a quarter of a million
pounds will be taxed at the full
25 percent rate that's bad news for
bad news for it's bad news for any
company that's earning
decent money right so like if you've got
a company that's making like 50 grand or
even
60 grand it'll probably affect you very
much but if you've got a company that's
making
2 million pound profit it's going to
change your tax
quite significantly yeah but it's not
going to come into 2023. we knew it was
coming
listen the government are giving out
money left right and center on furloughs
they have to cut it back somehow we
didn't know it's coming considering
considering i actually think these
aren't that bad no
i it's reasonable i thought it might go
up more than that it's reasonable yeah
and listen you know i thought they were
going to increase capital gains tax
they were talking about increasing it
they haven't have they
had no so if they've not increased
capital gains tax
that's mega that's great news it's not
it's not here but i i've not read it
yeah um it says that they're gonna
maintain inheritance tax thresholds
at their current levels until april 2026
so tax-wise generally speaking outside
of corporation tax
i think most people will love this
because like most
most people aren't being affected it's
just the big they are going after the
big company
yeah i mean i mean we know we we've paid
a lot of tax but now we're getting
cleverer and as robert kiyosaki says if
you know what you're doing anyway
and not paying much tax is not ripping
off the government it's just doing what
the government want
for example if you drive a tesla you're
gonna be able to count 100 of it back
why because they want you to drive a
tesla so do what they want and study the
rules and you're going to end up not
paying much tax
offset or offset losses against profits
keep your expenditures high be frugal
when you can't claim it back but when
you can be extravagant
i think these are all ways to keep tax
down so would you would you would you
buy would you buy an
uh interesting to my electric cars would
you buy an electric car next time
maybe maybe next that's tax what do you
think about the text changes comment
below what you think also smash the like
button if you're enjoying this video
because you know what i think it's
really important that people understand
what the
what this kind of what what's going on
yeah next government support an
extension of the coronavirus job support
scheme to september 2021
across the uk furlough is being extended
until september what do you think about
that
mixed go on mixed feelings about that um
every time they've extended in the past
do you know when they extended it to
was it march yeah last time everyone was
like oh brilliant news
and i was thinking no it's not brilliant
news because i kind of feel like we're
going to be in lockdown now until
okay so you're saying it's good news
that the the government are still
offering support with furlough but the
fact they've said it's till september
why do we need it why do we need to
september that because they're gonna
keep us in lockdown
that was what would suggest it would
then when we get onto the tourism it
would suggest maybe not
listen uh i don't know but it's one of
those where
when i first heard it my initial
reaction was great
we're going to be some sort of being
held back and whatever i understand
an extension of the uk wide
self-employment income support scheme
september 2021
with 600 000 more people who who filed a
tax return in 2019-20
now able to claim for the very first
time now the the self-employed people
have been absolutely hit absolutely
battered haven't they
with um with no support at
all and and and even this i know so many
people
who just can't apply for this because if
you're only more than 50
000 pounds a profit that is that's it
so this is only for a particular segment
of self-employed people
and from i listen i'm not self-employed
like
so i don't i haven't actually had this
issue so i haven't really looked into it
much
but from everyone i know that is
self-employed they're all like moaning
about it
so i i don't i listen it might be good
might be a good change but yeah
all right a new more this is a big one a
new mortgage guarantee scheme that will
enable all
uk home buyers secure a mortgage up to
six hundred thousand pounds with a five
percent deposit now i heard i haven't
looked into this too
oh i know all about this okay i heard
that it doesn't have to be you're not
actually a first-time buyer anymore
oh really apparently this is helped by
brother
i know but apparently you don't have to
build houses
uh i don't know guys
the five percent help to buy scheme is
bad
okay it's it's not help to buy
it's help to sell it's running new build
properties
for developers to be able to sell their
properties
at a high rate it's packages help to buy
i would enter help to buy scheme this
five percent deposit with caution
you're gonna have to live there yourself
this isn't for investment properties be
very cautious
i had a quick chat to steve bench about
this when i saw when i saw this came out
and he was like yeah it's basically the
same
it isn't it is i knew it was the same
without even looking into it it's just
obvious
i know they help to buy a scheme that
they keep saying it's going to end on
this day and then they put it back and
then put it back because they want you
to do it so bad because it's good for
them
it's good for it keeps house prices high
but it's not really great
because you're going to get a rope
around your neck you're going to have to
pay the money back anyway
you're going to have to live there the
whole would be left in negative equity
is sort of sticking around a bit like
the dfs sale isn't it it's like you know
oh it's going to end soon and it never
does
it never does right six-month extension
of the 20 pounds per week
universal credit uplift in great britain
with the northern ireland executive
receiving additional funding to match
the increase a one-off payment of 500
pounds to the eligible working tax
credit claimants across the uk
all right great six months extension of
the 20 pounds per week universal
so if you're on universal credit you're
gonna get an extra
you're gonna continue getting 20 pounds
a week i don't i don't really know that
much about that but it doesn't sound
exciting at all well you say that but i
mean 20 pounds a week that would pay
for samuel 365. that'll pay for
unlimited mentoring
coaching cause of you training with you
you're getting 20 pound a week
no wouldn't well pretty much what's 20
pound a week it went on a five week
month
it's 95 pound a month isn't it you know
what no no you can't say it would
have 20 pound a week 20 times 4.333 is
going to be about 80 pounds brother it's
about 85 quid isn't it
you there are there abouts all right
well you do get a one-off payment of 500
pounds
you get the rent of an accelerator as
well you know what i'm saying
anyway you're right everyone helps next
a new uk wide recovery loan scheme to
make available loans between 25 thousand
pounds
and one pen to know and ten million and
ten million
an asset and invoice finance between a
thousand and ten million to help
businesses of all sizes that's basically
like a bounce back loan uh replacement
right
we don't we haven't heard much about
these yet i did have a little look into
this
but bounce back loans were brilliant oh
my goodness that's right
that's not just a thing you know i know
c bill if you haven't applied for a
bounce back loan
do it c bills were terrible from my
experience
that's only because they were it was
hard to get well yeah
not hard to get it was impossible to get
right so yeah
terrible okay but bands but then bounce
back loans were great i mean who knows
but
yeah listen if you haven't got a bounce
back loan yet i think it's ending on the
end of march we don't know what the
recovery loan scheme is it might be
something similar
get a bounce back loan and you're gonna
have to pay the money back but it's
what percentage is it two percent it's
free free for a year and then two
percent for five years
right if you can't borrow money
and make money with that money when
you're paying two percent
interest you suck and you shouldn't even
be watching i'm free for a year
free for a year i mean yeah get a bad
spec loan invest it any way you can
make money on it but make sure you you
don't you know you do it legally and
properly all right extension of the
apprentice hiring incentive in england
um to september 2021 an increase of
payment
to 3 000 i think that's really good that
means they're paying you
3 000 pounds to have an apprentice if
you've got a business
or a little business maybe you're
self-employed and you want to just hire
somebody because i can't
afford to hire somebody stop doing those
five pound ten pound an hour jobs
get an apprentice get three thousand
pounds off the government to just have
an apprentice they're paying you to have
someone and then you pay the price how
much you've
got 2.53 per hour it's it's very cheap
i've
a little bit of experience with having
apprentices and and it's always been
i think it's pretty good it's pretty
good they're not
when i did it i don't know what it's
like now it was a few years ago and i
had a couple
and you have to one day a week they've
got to study and stuff it's not quite
like having a full-time member of staff
but it's very basically free it's
helping someone get started and get
and you're getting someone to do yeah
it's brilliant it's much better than
going to college i think
to have been afraid it's brilliant for
them it's brilliant for you the
government are encouraging it next
a new help to grow scheme to
offer up to a hundred and thirty
thousand companies across the uk
a digital and management boost yes what
is the help to grow skin so the help to
grow screen basically it's a little bit
like what we do
in a way it's training business owners
yeah so
um i'd look into this it's a 12-week
program
and you get like a business mentor you
get put into a group you get lots of
training progress a bit like samuel 365
but for for business um i actually think
it's really good the government are
putting together it's meant to be
rrp price so the usual price usual price
the investment is
uh seven and a half grand yeah but
they're doing a special
right now where the government will fund
90 of that so you only have to pay
750 quid okay so 750 pounds yeah
and it's 12 course 12 weeks you're going
to get mentoring
advice business training you know what
i'm going to do that you can do it i'm
going to do that course
yeah what do you reckon 750 quid why not
i think it's really good that the
government are encouraging people
to get business training i agree i i i
agree
i think i think is really good yeah if
only they would encourage it in schools
if only they would have money and
financial literacy as part of the
curriculum in schools
i'm pushing for that i'd be very
interested in fact i
really want you i want you to do it and
review it
because i'll document it great i'll
document it what the government's
business
training is like brilliant seven half
thousand pounds reduced if you buy now
[Laughter]
for for 750 pounds it's a great offer
i'll run to the back and grab that right
now i'll get that
all right next tourism also a lot of
people you know it's not cheap is it
seven and a half grand for three months
of training it's like wait
it's people criticize you in particular
for like the prices of your courses not
know my courses will be way better than
that nice
it just shows the value really my
courses will be way better than their
courses but i'll do it
i'll i'll document it good and i'll say
how good they're training
do it love it right next tourism um all
right 2.8 million for a world cup
bid yeah so 20 20 30 they are putting in
the they want england want us to have
the world cup here in 2013. i would love
it if we get the world it would be
brilliant for tourism
next this is what they're pushing for
they're putting 90
million into funding to support our
government-sponsored national museums in
england due to the financial impact of
kobe 19. it's brilliant
it's good i mean they're doing loads 28
million
28 million to fund the queen's platinum
jubilee celebrations in 2022
delivering a major celebration for the
uk i mean you could you could have a
good party for 28 million
you could have a great party people moan
about this sort of thing like oh the
queen they're spending all this money on
the queen celebration and the royal
family it's like
look man it's tourism yeah yeah it's
good
it brings it back to all the locals and
this kind of shows their intention as
well the fact that they're trying to
push to have the world cup here they're
trying to push to have
this big jubilee in 2022. i heard as
well i mean it's not in this but
um because you know euro 2020 got
cancelled
and moved to 2021 and it's supposed to
be like in all these different countries
across europe
but we are trying we're basically saying
look if you're going to struggle to do
everywhere we'll do it in england we're
trying to get in england that's like
this summer i think it's great
we should be encouraging that this um
they're also
doubling the legal limit for single
contactless payments from 45 pounds
to 100 pounds which is great i didn't
carry a wallet anymore
i don't apple pay all the way yeah
contact let's play the only time i get
unstuck
is on the toll roads yeah and you put a
bit of torah and you're like oh
no i literally don't have a card but
other than that apple pay all the way i
agree
all right so tourism so they're pumping
hundreds of millions
maybe not quite hundreds of millions
over 100 million yeah
into tourism um very very soon which is
great
regeneration i think this one's really
interesting they're putting 18.8 million
to
trans transform local cultural projects
in
hartley pool carlisle wakefield
and yellowville yoga i don't know that
place
but i didn't hardly pull hartley pool
right now is one of the cheapest parts
of the uk
it's so cheap i've got a friend nazi she
just bought a house in hartlepool
for 24 000 pounds right
she's that's just insane that is just
24 000 what's that is it like an
absolute wreck
look she spent 2 000 pounds lifting it
and now she's put a tenant in there
paying i think about 400 pounds of rent
you could
build the house for 24 grand i know it's
like
you'd have to make a profit in that area
as a developer you'd have to
they have to pay you to take the land
off you of them yeah
that's just but they're spending
millions regenerating these areas
so it's great hartley paul coming the
next big thing
there's so much negative equity in
hartleport is great for lease option
agreements
yeah it's great i agree in fact it's
very interesting if you look at the
regeneration if you wanna
you know people talk about capital
appreciation how can you possibly
predict and you
obviously you can't possibly properly
predict it because you never know what's
to happen with the housing market
but you can look for clues and signs and
in this section we'll
go through the regeneration there is
definitely and it tells you where
they're putting money yeah
what they're doing it's the same as like
with planning permission
it's like i used to think back in the
day it's like well how can you you're
just at the mercy of the
of the personality plan but you're not
the clues and stuff of that publication
of the prospectus for the 4.8 billion uk
wide leveling up fund
providing guidance for local areas on
how to submit bids for the first time
round of funding starting 2021 and 2022.
so again that's a massive fun to
to reject it's not i i might be wrong
but
is there certain areas can you see what
you can here i don't know
i don't know i think so i'm not 100 sure
on the leveling up fund but again it's
like it's good for the regeneration
yeah they're putting a lot a lot of
money into it over one billion funding
for a further
45 towns in england throughout towns
funds supporting their long-term
economic and social regeneration
as well as their immediate recovery from
the impacted covert 19. and again you
can look them up and see where they are
and see if there's areas needed and they
will tell you like it says here
eight new english free ports will be
based in east midlands airport
felix stowe and harwich humber liverpool
city region boom boom
plymouth solan thames and t side
i got houses in some of those areas like
t side some of those areas i have to say
i don't even know where they are i'll
probably pronounce some of them wrong i
got houses in some of these areas
and some of these areas where they're
regenerating proper you know they're
region bringing regeneration well
freeport so i've never heard of a
freeport
before today right when i saw this so go
on what's the freeport so
freeport from my very limited experience
looking it up
is but it's basically like a port so
that like they're obviously east
midlands airport it's mainly ports
though isn't it so it's when they're
importing goods it basically makes it
very very cheap
for people to import goods into the area
listen it's thursday
right now i gotta go because i gotta go
get my little girl she's just been born
i'm going to register her birth
right now which is far more interesting
than the budget but this is still really
interesting
i hope you enjoyed the video drop your
comments and thoughts below smash the
like button
subscribe i'll see you next time i'm
gonna go
i'll see you in a bit
[Music]